Hello belief nation today. I'm going to talk about seven ways and you can get started [with] zero dollars
So we get a lot of questions recently from people who?
Are trying to start a business and are trying to get funding and they feel like they can't get started until they have the funding?
And I'm here to tell you [that] I hate spending money until I'm making money. It's totally possible
I'm going to share with you seven ways and you can get started without spending any money on your business
Thank you for sharing your knowledge and expertise.  I've enjoyed your videos:                    Equity Valuation; Investor Valuation for Equity; 7 Things Not To Do to Start a Business; How to Start a Business with Zero Money...   I've learned a lot.
So you can start making it?
So the number one way is start with a service so many people feel like they need [to] have a product like how can I?
start a business until I've ordered my product and I have
Something to show people an easy way around it is start with [a] service start with a service by going out and talking to customers
Potential customers
Understanding what their problems are understanding how you can help them out a service business
Isn't as sexy because it's harder the scale because [your] trading time for money, and you don't want to do that as an entrepreneur
Right I want to build something really big and it's harder to make a huge service based company
But what it does at the beginning of a company is it gets you really close to your customer, right?
you really get to
Understand what they need what they don't need and it starts giving you cash flow right if you have a certain runway if you're doing
This part-time and you want to be able to quit your job or you have put your job
And you only have six months left of runway before you're going to run out of cash you need to start making money as soon
as you can and the fastest way to do it is through a
Service where you're connecting with a customer the other plus is when you are making [enough] money to support yourself
and you want to expand the product you already have a
Customer base that you can talk to and get their feedback on if they would buy that product or not and you have
Consistent cash flow coming in from your customers, so that it can support your product development
Or that [maybe] that first product doesn't work out you need to go to a second one
You don't have to go back to get a job because you have your service based business starting it off for you
It's not the big glamorous fun thing to do necessarily
All the time and it may not be the future vision of where you want your company to go
But starting with a service over a product helps you get [started] with no money and builds momentum for your business
number two is use Facebook as your
Website another common thing that I feel
Entrepreneurs are writing to me asking that they need money for is I need to launch my website [needs] to be [a] great website I
Need to have all my stuff up on there, and it's going to cost me
$10,000 or $5,000 or [$2,000] or whatever it is. I need to get my website up before I start my business
No, you don't start on Facebook
There's been a lot of massively successful companies who [just] started with their website as being a [Facebook] [fanpage]
That shares their information that has contact details, and there's been lots of business
We've started with no website at all and can a website help you
Absolutely any kind of marketing helps you but it's not worth spending the money at the start you need to be out there
Bringing in potential customers making some cash first then you can reinvest into your business if I had to pick any social Media platform I
Would pick Facebook to be my website that had my information a lot of its laid out for you
You don't have to be a tech genius to figure it out
You can have your picture you can have your hours you can put all your information up there
Start with a Facebook page instead of a website and as you start to make money
Then you can transition to building your own site and paying for it
My number [three] tip is go to them another reason why a lot of entrepreneurs want to spend money is they feel like you need
An office, I need an office an office is something. That's you know important
And it represents my brain and how we're going to have customer meetings
[I] can't ask them to come and meet me at home
Easy way around that is go to them [write] you want to meet with them about their business about their problems
Or what they're going through go to their office
It's a great way to do it because you get to see them in their setting you get to understand them better
They're comfortable you get to see their environment
It'll help you make a better [judgment] call and if you don't want to go to their office or maybe they don't have an office
And we don't feel [comfortable] in office. You didn't coffee shop
You know I [patent] office before I have this space here trying to dance Salsa all of my meetings are still held
At a Starbucks or a local coffee shop, [I] prefer it
I like the vibe of a coffee shop instead of being in the formal offices so the first thing that you do with your business
is not go get an office don't spend money on that instead invest into the
Relationships invested at the time and go meet them or meet at the coffee shop and use the money that you get to spend on
marketing and growing your business
My number [four] way to start without spending any money is make alliances
[a] lot of people need to raise money because they feel the [need] to go out and spend it on marketing
I need to take out an ad campaign I need to spend on Google Ads
Maybe not TV ads radio ads and newspaper ads and flyers and business cards and all the stuff in to go and spend money on
Don't spend money on that stuff
You don't know if it's going to work out or not and I hate the idea of you dipping into your pocket and you
Closing that window of how long you have to make this business a success
Instead spend your time to go out and make [alliance]
Partnerships all it's going to cost you is your time and your hustle and your energy and not your dollars find people who are [already]?
selling to your Target market
Who are not selling what you sell your service and go and connect with them and see how you can make some kind of arrangement
And if you spent your time lining up coffee meetings are going to their office to have
sessions with 20 the 30 to 40 people
we're all
Potential Lines partners some of those are going to work out and some of them are going to be referring clients to you and now
You're in business
and then the money that comes in you can figure [out] if you want to go and spend it on marketing and business cards and
[websites] and all this other stuff
But don't start spending on that until it comes in and the easiest way to grow business is through alliances
The people who are already selling to your target audience
Find a way to partner up with them
Not that they own a piece of your company
But [just] a way to pass business to each other if you do a good job
Servicing their clients it's a win for them think about who people are buying from
Before they buy from you or after they buy from you
What's the cycle of a product or service sale before or after they buy from you?
And who are they buying from who are you sandwiched in between?
go talk to all of those people and it's way easier having a partnership kind of
Conversation and [alliance] conversation, then a sales call for those of you who are afraid of picking up the phone and talking to customers?
It's way easier to talk about a potential alliance partnership
And how you may be able to work with each other then a sales call to a customer, so it's easier
It's less stressful
And [the] chance of you becoming a success are much higher because it's the fastest way to grow your [business]
And it doesn't have to cost you anything
My number five way is getting noticed [I'd] be using all of the free tools that I have at my disposal
And my hustle heart energy and drive
To get people to pay [attention] to me and get my name on People's radar
And so you can use social media right you can be posting from your own accounts
you can be connecting with people who already are known in your community so that you're part of their community and you get to
Connect with them you get to share their their advice and comment if you're trying to sell something that is
To the entre nous you want to connect with me you want to leave comments on my Facebook when I leave comments on my [YouTube]
You want to tweet [me] up?
[I] should know who you are [right] and not just selling me be part of the community first
Respond to some of the stuff that I'm putting out there share your comments interviews below so that you're a known quantity there are some
Of the people who leave comments on these videos that [I] know who they are because they do it
[consistently] and if they ask me for something to review their their product review their service check out their website, whatever it is
I would do it
I would say yes
because they've already contributed a lot back to me first, so
Investing in that hustle right you can connect with reporters connect with the Media
Write press releases and again if a reporter has covered your industry they need experts look at every article
That's written is always an expert opinion on there the reporter themselves. They're not the expert. They're generalist they always need that expert
Why can't you be the expert for your industry if they've written something before?
Usually have [their] twitter at the bottom or their email at the bottom?
Connect with them let them know what your thoughts are on the subject if you're an [entrepreneur]
You should be an expert at what you do so reveal that expertise
And you're making the lives of reporters easier as well
and so all of these strategies of being on your own social media connecting with other people on social media connecting with thought leaders and
Influencers [checking] with the media and press releases all of that stuff doesn't have to cost you anything
except your time your energy and your hustle to get people to pay attention to
My [Number-6] way to get started without spending money is to
pre-sell so a lot of people again feel like I need [to] raise capital to build my product and to get it out there and
to build the marketing and to
Actually create something where now it's never been easier to pre-sell and create campaigns if you look at websites like Kickstarter
[that] are out there where you only actually have to go out and produce whatever it is you say you're going to produce if you?
raise enough money to be able to do it and now you can't just
Put an idea up on Kickstarter
and hope it's going to take off the companies that do the best the companies that raised millions of [dollars] it comes that achieve their
Goals are the ones that are out hustling?
Afterwards right you launch your campaign you have to make a beautiful video around it and again
You could you know ideally you're working with somebody, but if not you [just] do it yourself
Then connect with the media and connect with influencers and drive people to that page
So they're attached to the mission what you're all about and they love it
And they want to preorder it and if you don't get it you don't get enough sales
Then you actually have to go out and create that thing [that's] going to cost you a lot of money part of being an entrepreneur
Is constantly trying to figure out? How else can I do this? How can I be more resourceful?
It's never about the resources you have it's about the resourcefulness that you have
It's being able to do what you can with what you have
Instead of focusing on the things that you don't have and if you keep focusing on those things you don't have then you're never going
To be the success you're always going to have a cop-out you're always going to have a reason and you're never going to drive forward
on your path
And so pre-selling is a great way to do that before you actually launch it to see if there's an appetite for it
So that when you do launch it you have the money to pay for it
And my number seven way to get started without spending any money is to barter is to trade think about the things that you need
To spend money on and find people that you can make that kind of connection [with] where you are
Trading with each other so as an example when I had sold my first business. I was looking to
Start something [new] and I wanted to I wanted to have some office space [right] I want to have office space with my own rule
Don't spend on office space, so [I] made a deal with a local venture capital company where I got to be [a] part of their
Operation I was helping bringing deals. I got a
desk at their
Location which was at [yonge] new [King] for those of you who know Toronto is one of the most prestigious
Addresses that you can have in the city
It's right in the downtown core, [and] I got the office space for free and as I started building up my new company
I had four to five the six sometimes people working at that office for free
Because I bartered because I was helping bring in deals for that business whatever it
Is that you feel that you really need?
Find somebody who can provide it for you and figure out what they want because money is a currency
but there may be something else that you can do for them so you can trade to get to where you want to go and
again
it's about being resourceful and
Not about the resources you have so that's the summary of the seven things that I [think] you can do to start a business without
Having to spend any money at all. [I'm] curious. What do you guys think of the video? What did you learn from it?
What can you apply to your company?
And then I missed some is there an 8 9 [10] that maybe should be on the list
Leave it in the comments below and I'm going to join in the discussion
I also want to give a quick shout out to Allen Conway allen
Thank you so much for buying a copy of my book really really really really means a lot to me
Those are you watching if you want your chance at a shout out in a future video make sure to
Pick up a copy of the book
It's really good an email in your seat, so that we can keep track and [see] the bonuses
Thank you guys so much for watching continue to believe or whatever your one word is and I'll see you soon